los reclamos al gobierno colombiano no
cesan cuando está a punto de cumplirse
un mes de protestas los manifestantes
rechazan que no se haya dado aún
respuesta a sus peticiones y tiran la
pelota al campo del ejecutivo para
terminar la crisis depende
fundamentalmente de que el gobierno
atienda esas peticiones y de alguna
manera la gente evalúe si se resuelven
los problemas sociales que tienen que
ver con el hambre con la pobreza con la
exclusión por ejemplo si tenemos una
renta básica otras exigencias son el
acceso universal a la educación superior
el desarme del escuadrón antidisturbios
y una reforma policial ante las
constantes denuncias de abusos de la
fuerza pública en las protestas la ong
local temblores resalta 60 asesinatos en
las manifestaciones 43 atribuidos a la
fuerza pública pero aún en esta
situación el gobierno es renuente a la
entrada de veedores internacionales
solicitamos al gobierno colombiano que
permita
entrada de la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos para que ellos en el
terreno se den cuenta que es lo que ha
ocurrido en nuestro país en cuanto a
violación de derechos humanos en contra
de declaraciones previas y tras la
presión la vicepresidenta a marta lucía
ramírez abrió la puerta a una entrada
anticipada de la comisión
en una ruptura con el gobierno nacional
la alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez
entregó un informe a la representante de
la alta comisionada de naciones unidas
para los derechos humanos sobre la
violencia ocurrida en la capital que
incluye la investigación de la muerte de
dos jóvenes por otro lado la corte
suprema del país hizo un llamado al cese
inmediato de la violencia después de que
una turba incendiara el palacio de
justicia del municipio de tuluá cercano
a la ciudad de cali epicentro de las
protestas las altas cortes no han
rechazado el uso desmedido de la fuerza
policial